because all sodality the cheese games
and other stuff
hi everyone thank you for letting me
invite myself to this workshop
yeah so it's a long story this 2 to 2
game stuff it's a sequence of like 4
papers will you read and myself are on 2
and there is some contribution from
Barak and [ __ ] italian-style and I
thought I would also talk about some
newer work with the non Lipchitz and
David Ellis but when I prepared the talk
I realize that I will not have time for
this and right so I I need to define
these two to two games and it all starts
with the gap problems we started this
work started when PC peas were about
approximation and gapper problems and
not about blockchains and so yeah so
it's like regular old NP problems like
you have a glass and you want to know
what a network are yeah yeah so maybe
you want to find a maximal clique so a
maximal fully connected set of vertices
so the gap version may be a 1/2 0.1 gap
a version of this is where we all
promised that in the completeness sighs
I don't know exists a clique of size 1/2
recovering half of the vertices
oh the maximal clique is much tinier is
only point one of the vertices and the
gap version is the given de-spawn is to
distinguish between the two so that's a
gut problem and if you know that a gut
problem is np-hard then you also know
that the
how to approximate that's a simple
exercise and the way that usually you
show that a gut problem is hard is via a
PCP for ballistically checkable proof
that's one way of looking energy oh no
some and it involves at least in in a
very significant way some local to
global phenomenon
so inside typical PCPs you will find
error correcting codes and local tests
for them so an algorithm code can be
regular reed-solomon atom out long code
there are many codes but for a PCP also
need a query efficient a code test so
that's a code that's a test that queries
only a queue entries from the entire a
word that's the local part and then it
either accepts or rejects and then if
the probability of acceptance is greater
than some parameter Delta then you know
that the word that you are given is
close in some sense to a code word so
that's the global part right because the
code word is global and you only checked
a constant number or a very small number
of entries and it's not clear how to get
a PCP form a code test but it's clear
that the code test that you use for the
PCP it either determines or at least
limits the parameters of the PCP that
you get so you want Co tests with good
properties and here's something that I
should have said at the end but maybe I
will never get to it so I will say it
now that there is some deep although not
totally understood relation between
efficient tests for codes and an
expansion or small set expansion and
there's
so some relation between this and hyper
conductivity and and these relations
play a big part in in this world
hopefully we'll be able to see some of
it okay so here is a quick well-known
example of a code test so the code is
the set of linear functions from F to
the k2 F well F is some small field
maybe and then the bloom
Looby loo Rubenfeld test says okay
you've given all the values of this
function you want to know that it's Lin
I'll just pick two points at x and y and
see if f of X plus F of Y really equals
f of X plus y and if F is really linear
then you have completeness one yeah all
right you accept always and it turns out
that you can get the soundness to be
half plus Epsilon anything greater than
1/2 of course a random function we
satisfy this equation with probability
1/2 if the foil field of size 2 right
and building on this test hostel gets
optimal hardness for linear equations
with three variables in each and this is
a three query test right you check it X
and network and at F and at X plus y and
for getting to 2 2 game hardness we will
need the only two queries yeah all right
so I will show you what you need games a
well unique games and two to two games
of similar I will show you both of them
and then it will be clear why we need
two queries so an instance of unique
games is a system of linear equations
that's not the
a general definition but it's actually
equivalent so I'm not cheating here yeah
with this lesson here so you have a
bunch of linear equations each equation
has just two variables over some a field
modulo Q well Q is a load constant and
you want to solve as many of the
equations as possible by assigning the
variables
yeah so just as a remark max cut which
is a well-known optimization problem is
the case where Q the size of a field is
to write and the unique games conjecture
of code says that distinguishing whether
you can satisfy almost all equations or
whether you cannot satisfy almost none
of them that's np-hard at least that's
the conjecture if you take Q the size of
the field to be allowed this seems to be
a strong conjecture so we assume a lot
but it's also powerful because it gives
a lot if you assume it
right so that's the conjecture again and
here are some of the things that you get
from it you get you get tight you know
you you know exactly what is the best
approximation for many problems like max
Kurt this max clique that I mentioned
before Mattox norms to to scheduling
problems many many others and actually
there's a theorem of Ragavendra which is
very surprising and strong which says
that in some sense if your Sunday unique
games conjecture there is one particular
approximation algorithm that gives a the
best possible efficient approximation
for all constraint satisfaction problems
that's the theorem but it somehow holds
even in the cases that it's not stated
for so it's really a meta theorem so if
the unique games conjecture is true then
there is ya then approximation
algorithms out done of course that's not
completely true but never mind so yeah
so that makes the unique games
conjecture interesting we not we want to
know if it's true
there are integrality gaps that yeah
that point towards the truth be told it
being true
koten Moskowitz have some candidate
construction that if anyone manages to
analyze maybe it will give something
towards the only games some weak version
of it there are also other groups that
worked on algorithms that try to solve
this gap problem
so there are algorithm algorithmic
approaches that are non-trivial and give
some strong results although they do not
solve unique games in polynomial time
and there's more to tell but I will
continue so yeah
but we still don't know and therefore we
study similar things so here's a 2 - 2
games conjecture so you remember that in
the unique games we had a system of
equations mod Q that's a good time to
say why it's called a unique game right
when you have an equation X I minus XJ
equals 7
this means that for every assignment for
XJ there is a unique assignment for X I
which makes this equation true so that's
a one-to-one relation between assignment
to one variable and to the other for two
- - we need to - - relation and
therefore instead of equations with one
B we have equations with two B's and any
solution that gives either this or the
other is accepted so that's 2 - 2 games
and Here I am cheating a little but
never mind and in the same paper we'll
Subash stated the unique games
conjecture he also stated the 2 - 2
games conjecture which is that it is
np-hard to distinguish if you can
satisfy all of these constraints or you
cannot satisfy even Delta Y and here you
have perfect completeness which you
cannot have with regular linear
equations but that's a minor point for
this book yeah so that's a weaker
conjecture that then the unique games
conjecture although it still has some
interesting applications and in some way
which I will make clear in the next
slide this is half way to a unique games
conjecture that's a very formal way of
defining the half way but never mind and
yeah and the point is that if you take
all of these papers Plus this don't
a contribution by Barak Kota installer
you get almost two to gain conjecture
except that first of all I switch the
order between Delta and one with minus
Delta and also instead of 1 I have 1
minus Delta so it's almost perfect
completeness instead of perfect
completeness by accident yes yeah no
it's not yeah
it's not part of the result right yeah
like so yeah so what do you get from
this now
theorem the two two two games theorem
well you get optimal hardness of
approximation for various problems you
get less than optimal but still good
hardness of approximation for problems
like the click the gap click that we
discussed and keiko leaning and for
coloring but one interesting thing is
that you get that the unique games is
hard for the gap version where you have
half instead of 1 minus Delta so in that
sense it's 1/2 the way because no
constant was known before now we know
1/2 if we manage to multiply it by a
factor of 2 we are done what is less
it's less than optimal in the sense that
for if you assume the unique games do
you get something stronger yeah less
than the theoretical optimal yeah yeah
it might be yeah so that's some constant
versus Delta and the optimal is 1/2
versus Delta the theoretical optimal so
theoretically even if you're staring at
a graph well half of it is a clique
you cannot even find Delta click
right and the fact that the the two to
two games implies this actually kills a
lot of the algorithmic approaches to
unique games because these approaches do
not distinguish between a completeness
half and completeness one so at least it
it's a strong indication that the
attacks on the unique games conjecture
the current attacks will not work unless
P equals NP yes Lloyd yeah that's always
an option okay so yeah so you want to
get hardness for two to two games and as
I said inside you need some code that
fits what you want to get and yeah let
me talk about agreement test for codes
which is the type of code tests that we
use so you want to encode a set of code
words some nice you know functions over
some domain that have nice properties
and these functions you not want to
somehow encode in a way that you can
test maybe low degree functions for
example so here is a the domain so you
want to encode a function that is
defined over all the points here the
entries of the code will not be points
there will be collection of subsets of
the whole domain and any encoding of a
nice function will assign each of these
subsets with the restriction of the
function to the subject so if for
example this is the set of functions of
degree 5 we will only allow restrictions
that are 5 degree polynomials on these
subsets
and then the test will choose by some
distribution to different subdomains
that have some intersection and do the
obvious thing which is to test that the
assignment that we have on one subset
and the assignment that we have that we
have on on the other agree on the
intersection so that's an agreement test
yeah and for completeness of course if
these are all the sections of some
global function we will always accept so
we have compare completeness one and the
some parameter is Delta if we can
somehow prove that when the test accepts
is probability Delta then there must be
some global function that agrees with
many of the subdomains and many can have
many meanings and you really need to be
careful about what it means right so
such a huge yeah here's one good thing
about an agreement test at least the way
I described it it has two queries which
is good because eventually we want to
get equations with two variables in each
so that's the same - it's not the same -
as the 2 2 2 the 2 2 2 means that for
any assignment on this sub domain there
should be only two assignments on this
sub domain that that can agree with it
okay let's do it okay I'll retail to
that let me just say something about
agreement test they have a long history
I will not describe all of it I will
just mention a few of those ruby infants
who done which they used they tested
that the polynomial is of low degree by
having subdomains at other lines and
points and checking agreement between
them there's Gold Rush and suffer that
use similar tests for tens of products
or codes but they could not give a low
parameter of soundness and we once found
s Delta which is small there is less and
suffer we they used only sub domains
that are sub sub spaces with a small
dimension maybe Plains and they got a
low soundness and yeah so the point
there is that when you when the domains
are planes and the intersect on a line a
low degree polynomial on a line is still
a code and then you can just test on a
on a single point okay I will not go
into it and there's over Sudan which did
the same but with lines and points and
alright okay and here I go back to where
I was before a I want the authority to
be to I want an agreement test well if I
know the assignment of one work variable
it determines almost completely the
assignment of the other variable up to
maybe there could be two options so
let's say let's see how we can make the
allottee of an agreement test b2
[Music]
right so yes so the the finish of the
reality is what I said you fixed an
assignment for one valuable and you only
need and there could be only our options
for the other variable so in heart
suffer when they tested two planes if
you you wanted a low soundness but then
you had the RT love gel so we need a
little two and four yeah and that's in
some sense if you want the unique games
conjecture or not the two to two a
conjecture you win you need a little one
in some sense which is not clear so
that's why we don't know how to attack
it
yeah means any constant greater than
zero that's what we want
right so right so if but if we start
from doesn't suffer so we have these
planes and we pick two planes that
intersect well if I know the assignment
of this plane there are still many
options to an assignment for this plane
as long as the field is large so we need
a small field optimally we need a field
of size 2 and also even random
assignments especially when the field is
of size 2 we'll agree with some constant
probability if I only look at planes so
actually instead of planes I need
subspaces of larger dimensions so still
constant but a constant that depends on
the soundness that I want to reach it
depends on the parameters so yeah right
now
yeah and so so now you have some
subspaces that intersect you want the
value on one to determine almost
completely the value on on another so
you want a minimal freedom for the
assignment of the other and for that you
need the code dimension like you want
the other to be of dimension maybe one
mole of a of the intersection because
then assigning the other one only
requires choosing a value on one new
base vector and you also want linear
degree so let's try to sum this now you
have the global function will be Li now
and therefore on each domain you expect
a linear function
and right and then when you when you
assign one domain it almost fixes the
assignment to the other domain except
for one new base vector that you need to
add that on that the function can be
either 0 or 1 so there are only two
options and when you realize that you
get what it's called the glassman test
so that's the Glassman kotas which
appeals in the first paper yeah so you
have the field of is of size two you are
going to encode functions from F to the
K to F well K is a very large constant
and the subdomains will be a sub spaces
of dimension L which is a small constant
small large constant M right and yeah
and to encode your sign to encode a
function f to each and 3lu assigned the
restriction of f2l and the test is you
pick two subspaces with that intersected
in the largest dimension possible and
you accept if they agree on the
intersection so that's the agreement
test that we need for to get to two to
here's a picture and as I already said
this is a two to two agreement test once
you fix the assignment to one there are
only two assignments to the other
it makes sense yes but but the point is
that if these were quadratic functions
even if the field is of dimension 2 and
the intersection is the loud as possible
you lose the yes you lose the oddity as
an agreement test yeah it makes sense to
consider it not immediately not that I
see yeah even even analytics even
analyzing this test is quite non-trivial
and I I don't know how to generalize
immediately yes right yeah that has hope
of getting perfect completeness yeah so
yeah no I'm I'm not saying it's not
industry we just no I'm just saying I
don't know how to do it yeah right
obviously
yeah with when everything is leaner you
can't get perfect company so yeah
right so now the question is you know it
obviously has perfect completeness it's
only the soundness that remains so if we
can get Delta soundness for any constant
positive constant Delta then well done
so let's assume that this test has some
as Delta and let me in one slide say how
do you get to to to a hardness result
for the you know the gap to to to a
hardness even that is complicated and
eventually you don't get Delta soundness
not in the usual sense
so it's eventually it's even more
complicated than that
but let me just say you know assume that
we you do have this Delta soundness what
would you do so okay if you're an expert
you will know this and if not you'll get
hopefully something from this slide but
maybe not a lot so you start with a PCP
theorem sorry
and you get by a trick
[Music]
yeah so the PCP Salem is itself hardness
for some gap constraint satisfaction
problem and from that you get some even
smaller gap hardness for label cover and
then you do power the petition and that
you get you get a big gap for label
cover and then the standard thing would
be to use the variables in the label
cover and and encode them we are
whatever new shiny test that you have in
this case it's this Glassman code it
doesn't work because you we only know
how to encode linear functions yeah so
cannoli encode linear functions so
instead you you can follow hast a
hostage trucks and encode everything by
the long code and get hardness for
filling our equations a mode two and
then from that get a small gap for a
label cover which is leaner and then
yeah and by using hardness for thrilling
you use you lose completeness and then
that's a small gap you want a loud gap
so you apply power repetition and then a
then you get a linear label cover with
the loud gap and you apply harder mode
encoding and hard to the variables and
harder mode encoding is and encoding by
linear functions so to that you can
apply the classman encoding and then by
yeah you need the coupled version of
this guy Gausman test and you need
folding and other things but eventually
you get the hardness that you wish this
is all assuming that does the tester
sounds Delta okay so now forget about
that let's return to the grassman test
and think whether it really has
soundness Delta
so now soundness
okay so forget all these PCP stuff you
have on someone gives you a linear
function on every subspace of constant
dimension and if you pick two that
intersect with on a diamond codimension
one subspace then there's a probability
of at least Delta that they agree on the
intersection does it imply that there is
a global lineal function that agrees
with a non negligible fraction of the
local assignments so that's the question
that's the soundness question the answer
is no there doesn't need to be such a
global function so let me give you an
example but before I give you a so I'm
going to give you an example of an
assignment that satisfies the test but
there's no big global function but
before that let's do this trick suppose
I pick L and L Prime randomly except
with the constraint that they intersect
on the co dimension one subspace and let
X be some point in L what is the
probability that X is also in L Prime
okay so this is the this is 0 this is
the subsidized L and hopefully the next
year so and here is X but I know about L
prime is that it is that it contains a
subspace of code dimension one inside L
and this is a field of size two so a
subspace of code dimension one contains
half of the points and therefore the
probability that this yeah so here is a
politician of the space to the to call
closets and the probability that X is
containing the one that also contains
zero is one half and that's the other
subspace that contains this co set that
contains zero so the answer is roughly
one-half there is a minor correction
that you need because of zero but yeah
so about 1/2 which here is another way
of saying it define Z X to be all the
subspaces that contain X that's called
the zoom in set for X so that's all the
ELLs that contain X and what we just
said is that Z X has a stamp of a bigger
1/2 if you start at an element of Z X
and then you go to a neighbor this
neighbor is also going to be in the X
with probability 1/2 oh and I also
another way of saying it is if you
consider the pairs of subspaces that
that the test considers you consider
them as a graph so you have an edge
between two subspaces that the test can
check both this subspace this graph has
set such as Z X that are completely not
expanding right there if you do a random
walk inside the X
at each step there is a high probability
of staying inside the X so you're
connecting to subspaces if their
intersection is of Co dimension one and
in this graph Z X is a non expanding set
so this is not an X so we took the test
we used it to define a glove and I just
told you that this graph is not
expanding and that's actually the reason
why I can construct a an assignment that
satisfies Delta function of the tests
but but is not global and the way to do
it is just here's the zoom in set again
and now for every X in the original big
domain just pick an arbitrary global
randomly a global function a global
inner function f of X and then for every
set probably a subset L that contains X
just I sign it the restriction of FX so
actually you need to like sort all the
XS in some arbitrary fashion and then
the first X that is also contained in L
it gives the assignment to it and
because ZX has this high staying for
mobility when the test considers L and
its neighbor there is a high probability
that they'll both assigned by the same X
and therefore the test will accept with
large some constant large constant
probability but each of these sets Z X
is actually tiny right what is the
probability that a subspace of some
small dimension will contain a specific
point X it's really time
so you have a huge number of these sets
and no global function because for each
set there's a completely different
assignment yeah and those of course Bowl
how much time do I have how much smoke
and eat though
right so this so this zoom in said
looking at all subsets that contain a
certain point X that's a non expanding
set there are other non expanding sets
that you can use to give other counter
examples so there was a zoom out set
where you look at all subspaces el that
are contained in some loud subspace W
and you can do the same tricks there
cause of the sting probability is 1/2
and you can get a counter example from
that as well right so there is no Delta
soundness in the usual sense Delta
soundness in the usual sense what
because we've seen to counter examples
and when you encounter such counter
examples and you really want to get
something then usually what you say is
maybe these are the only examples that
exist
usually it's wrong but in this case it
is it is right it is correct it works so
this was a conjecture at some point that
if the test accepts with probability
greater than Delta then you can then
there is a global function that maybe
doesn't agree with all with a large
fraction of all the subspaces but it
does agree with a large fraction of
subspaces that are contained in some
small code dimension subspace W and
contains a subspace of small dimension Q
so there is this zoom there is some
combination of zoom in and zoom out
where inside that tiny set
of subspaces there is a global function
that agrees with a non-negligible
function right so just like a X was used
to assign all the subspaces in Z X so
for this subspaces in Zechs there was a
global function it was just that the X
is a tiny set so yeah so that was the
conjecture and and it was eventually
proven yeah that I will not go into this
remark now you all seem too tired for
that
exactly zq z q is all the subspaces that
contain qzw is all the subspaces that
are contained in W and this is all the
sets that contain Q and our contained in
W so this is a zoom in/out lens
something and when the test accepts
there is such tiny sub no tiny part
within the whole entries of the codeword
that do agree with some global function
and from this you can get the two to two
if yours if you believe that then you
can get the two to two conjecture it's
not easy because that's only you get a
global function that agrees with a tiny
fraction of your code word so you need
to do some extra stuff but but that
works
I don't need uniqueness of qmw and
actually what I do use is that if there
are such Q and w's because that's such a
tiny set then they can't explain all of
the acceptance probability of this test
there must be also either other cues and
w's that that also exist so I can take
this Q and W that well ruin the
assignment to the subspaces here the
acceptance probability of the test will
still be rather high because I only wind
the tiny set and therefore there must be
other Q and W the twork so there there
are many of those there's no uniqueness
and actually that's what we need yeah so
it's a little misleading if there are
this Q and W there actually exist many
perils of Q and W right but you have
yeah you have a to approval system and
they they need to somehow agree on which
Q and W to look at there's still stuff
to do there's a lot of stuff to do
and
right and then okay I will say only a
few words on what goes on so basically
here the conjecture just says that the
code test works maybe in a weak way but
it works and if we have the code test
then we have to work but then we get the
two to two conjecture
now we need to show that the test works
and the first thing that we did is to
think okay maybe the test doesn't work
and if it doesn't work there must be
other small sets that have high stank
probability other than the kinds that we
already know all right so this is the
graph that I already defined and there
was another conjecture that says that
the only sets that have a high stank
probability our sets which are of this
form or at least have some large set
which is roughly of this form yeah and
from here the story I will not go with
the slides because there's not enough
time I'll just tell more or less the
story right so we at least this version
we managed to prove not fall Delta but
for some parameters in this paper and
there was a paper of Doven muli and
Subash that got the whole Delta so at
least we knew that this works in terms
of the structure of the graph it has the
small set expansion properties that we
thought it should have
but a barack and Qatari and Steuer noted
that there is a maybe three line poof
that shows that if you have this
expansion the structured expansion
property of the graph then you also have
that the test actually works in the
sense that is written here and therefore
we have the two to two conjecture and
the way that you prove that the graph
has the required expansion properties is
by looking at now I forgot the word
spectral the composition of the graph
and yeah but these are not magic words
spectral decomposition is just the first
step and then there's a lot a lot a lot
of very complicated work and this work
that I ate was grayed out with norm and
David we managed to reprove this
property in a way that is somewhat
simple but unfortunately I will not have
time to say anything more about that
all right so yeah so Hilo other slides
and here are some open problems so yeah
it would be nice to prove the unique
games conjecture I have to put it there
yeah all right but this work required
something that I'm not sure why so
before certainly not in computer science
there's a lot of work about expansion
and even the relation between expansion
and codes the original linearity test of
bloom Lu be an open field I'm not sure
that this was the original poof but one
early proof for the soundness of this
test uses expansion in some graph so
this structure was known the new thing
here is that we don't have a graph that
is expanding we have a graph where we
know the structures of the sets that are
not expanding so we don't have expansion
we just know that whenever expansion
doesn't work there's a specific reason
for that and we somehow managed to still
use it but it it might be usable in many
other situations there's no no that's
not low-degree that's that small set
small set in low degree somehow consume
the same space in my head and yeah and
of course you use it for interactive PCP
or blockchains or whatever so that's
also option yeah and then I recently
took a drawing as a hobby so that's also
true
[Applause]
so maybe a mistress but from that I have
come without that hardness for you to
see to go all the way down to something
closer to one is there so this approach
would not work but if there are other
part like where what parameters of this
test okay I'm not sure I understand the
question I'll say it anyway
a because okay there's a that's just one
image that I should have said during the
talk which is if you have an instance of
two to two games and and you know that
it's hot so either it is completely or
almost completely satisfiable all
there's no assignment that satisfies
even Delta fraction of the constraints
it's easy to make it into an instance of
unique games that is on either side of
the 1/2 + Delta gap by just for each
each constraint is this - 2 - like for
each assignment here you you get two
options on the other side so just select
one of them randomly so this changes the
constraints is from 2 to 2 constraints
into 1 to 1 constraints and the same
assignment that that satisfies all the
constraints before now it will in
expectation satisfy 1/2 and it also
works on the other side of the gap so so
the way that you get to 1/2 Delta unique
games is by a simple exercise and this
1/2 comes from the inverse of 2 in 2 to
2 and and therefore as I said if you
want to go from 1/2 to 1 you need at
least using this approach you need
agreement tests where when you see
you know the test looks at two variables
but when it sees the assignment to one
variable it already knows exactly what
the assignment of the other variable
should be and that seems to create a lot
of problems so we do know tests that are
like that which is hinted towards that
told in the talk we do know tests that
are one-to-one but test is not enough
what we need is to able to use the test
not just to check that something is a
code word but we needed a coupled
version where we have two code words and
we need at the same time to check that
one is a code word the other is also a
code word and that the things that
encode satisfy a certain constraint and
that we don't have and it's and and and
this - in the - - - enables us to do it
and it's at least to me it's not clear
at all how to move from from this to
something that approaches the unit games
you say it somehow the to-to-to it's
enough that you just individually chat
but two things are code words me no no
no no there's much that goes into it
it's not simple but it's doable
yeah I'm not okay I cannot really tell
you how it works but just as a vague
intuition if you have two linear
functions one owned F to the K and the
other also an F to the K but it's a
slightly different case so you have like
a harder mode encoding of a set of
variables and a hard about encoding of a
slightly different set of variables in
this in these two harder mode encodings
there are many subspaces of small
dimension that are shared between those
two encodings
and you can somehow check the
consistency of one so you can check the
consistency of a subspace in the in one
hard encoding and a versus the subspace
that actually comes from the hard amount
encoding of a different set of variables
as long as these sets are almost the
same
yeah and they for the unique games you
need that they are exactly the same and
then it means that instead of doing a
small step you're doing an zero step and
yeah so and there's a big difference
thanks guy
[Applause]